this is the story I've wanted to pitch
my entire life I go in there I go I'm a
fat I like Trump a little bit I mean I'm
thrown out I get thrown out we broke the
story of the Gilbert goons in Arizona
and I was the one leading the charge to
try to get Justice for this sad this
poor child who was killed now this group
of people we know is largely suburban
and white and the New York Post look at
this on the front page of the newspaper
and there's no pictures of any of the
white people so people tend to get maybe
confused the black guy's name is Mr
Fantastic which
again he not helping that doesn't help
anybody and I'm trying to buy the IP I
call CAA I call these people they're
always like I mean we can't write you
any checks here we can't be involved we
can't do anything with you